est encore long et sarah lenka vous
emmène en voyage celui des chanteuses
jazz des années 20 30 le jazz la jeune
artiste le découvre à londres j'ai
empanné jeetoo du jazz et du coup c'est
j'ai voulu mélanger
voilà c'est fait de monde on fait faire
une passerelle on va dire je sais pas
une fan inconditionnelle
a la base je viens pas du tout là et
c'est parce que j'écoute est
naturellement sur le jazz pendant des
heures mais déjà un j'ai appris à
l'entendre j'ai appris à l'apprécier
comprendre ces subtilités et puis on va
dire que j'ai un jazz qu'elle tint de
folk blues désigné meilleur artiste
vocale féminine par la sacem en 2007
sarah lenka sur un troisième album en
un hommage à b6 méfie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
six hommes
detry smith elle elle m'a parlé par son
franc parler déjà elle avait une manière
de raconter sa vie et de chanter ces
histoires ne s'était pas le bo qui prime
est en fait c'était vraiment voilà quel
que soit le sentiment qu'elles ont
rejoint quelque chose de beau gosse de
moosch le le disait comme s'était rayé
pas de filtre et c'était très triste et
très vrai et moi j'ai adoré ça c'est
aussi une femme des premières femmes qui
a ouvert le chemin parce que c'était la
première femme chanteuse noire qu'a
réussi et je pense à important ce
concert dégage tantôt de l'humour tantôt
de la puissance avec son timbre éraillé
sarah lane quatre ans mais son envie de
partager
et vous en vous
[Musique]